flv juste pour moi en fait ses neuf
médailles malgré les coûts élevés
mylène salvat a opté pour la fécondation
in vitro l'afcv est la première ivg
c'est un échec gels est pris durement
j'étais extrêmement stressé et en fait
c'est sophos heures et essayer la femme
de 40 ans n'aurait pas pu choisir
l'autre méthode de procréation assistée
l'insémination artificielle car son
conjoint a eu un renversement de base
etc tommy ce qui ne lui permet pas d'y
recourir à l'insémination artificielle
consiste à déposer du sperme dans
l'utérus
elle est remboursée par la ramq eu la
fécondation in vitro elle vise à
extraire les ovules de la patiente afin
de réaliser la fécondation en
laboratoire
l'embryon est ensuite transférés dans
l'utérus
cette dernière méthode est plus complexe
mais parfois inévitables lorsque le coût
représente une condition médicale
particulière comme c'est le cas de
madame salvat ce qui distingue aussi la
ff iv de l'insémination c'est son coût
plus élevé d'autant plus que les plus
remboursés depuis 2015 en général je
pense que ça diminue de 50 à 70 selon
des médecins consultés par radio canada
depuis la fin de la gratuité la
fécondation in vitro a été délaissé par
de nombreux couples d'autres une
minorité aurait choisi de se tourner
vers l'insémination artificielle
le nombre d'inséminations artificielles
remboursés par le gouvernement a
légèrement augmenté il est passé de près
de 15000 en 2014 à près de 18 mais en
2017 selon les données de la ramq eu
beau couple je les vois tous les jours
qui arrivent à la criée qui présentait
une panne une position de destination
parce qu'on prépare pas se permettre de
trop mais je sais que ça va difficile
pour eux d'avoir un bébé on a fini
nation dans certains cas il y en a pour
qui ça va les plus jeunes
ce qui pour qui c'est un problème avait
là thouars ça va ça va sûrement marché
un crédit d'impôts est offert pour la ff
iv mais sous certaines conditions
deux mille personnes y ont eu accès en
2016 selon revenu québec
je comprends que le programme coûter
cher au gouvernement puis essayer de
trouver des alternatives avec les
crédits d'impôt cependant les crédits
d'impôt sont peu accessibles juste le
fait que mon conjoint et eu un enfant il
y a dix huit ans on n'a pas le droit un
nouveau crédit d'impôt au bureau du
ministre de la santé qui est en
barrettes
on n'exclut pas l'idée de remettre en
place la gratuité mais seulement si
l'état des finances publiques le permet
avoir des enfants je me dis si c'est une
des plus belles choses que la vie peut
t'apporter tous que mylène salvat
souhaite c'est d'agrandir sa petite
famille et si marie laurence de l'aîné
radio canada montréal